1.
The sun radiates more energy in 15 minutes
than humans use every year around the world.
If only we could find a way to channel the
sun's energy more efficiently.
2.
You can make electricity from anything.
Light, wind, water and even animal manure.
The most common way of producing electricity
around the world is by burning coal.
3.
In the early 1900s christmas lights were so
ridiculously expensive that they were often
rented instead of sold.
If you had lights at christmas, it was a big
status symbol.
4.
A single bolt of lightening can contain up
to 3 million volts, that's enough electricity
to serve over 200,000 homes.
Also lightening can be up to five times hotter
than the surface of the sun.
5.
Electricity is lazy, it will find the quickest
path to the ground.
Did you know that electricity can "jump",
it can literally leap across a distance to
find the nearest source of earth.
The higher the voltage the further it can
jump.
This is why you have to be super careful around
live wires and power sockets.
6.
Your heart works on electricity.
Muscle cells in the heart are contracted by
electricity that passes through it.
Electrocardiogram or ECG machines, AKA heart
rate monitors, used in hospitals work by measuring
how much electricity is going through the
patients heart.
This causes the erratic movements of the line
you see on screen.
7.
Electricity can be used to create the world's
most powerful magnets, commonly known as electromagnets.
8.
Iceland was the first ever country to produce
all of its electricity from renewable sources.
Go Iceland!
9.
Electricity travels at the speed of light,
that's more than 186,000 miles every second.
10.
But what actually is electricity?
It's the flow of charged particles, electrons
and protons, around a closed circuit.
Electricity cannot flow if a circuit is not
a complete loop.